[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to top the record
where we talk about Jim Beam huh Dean is
not good at all buddy have you guys been
drinking more chase it with Jen
absolutely I think the whole world's
been drinking more I think I've been
drinking more just from here from being
here I've had more alcohol than my past
two weeks you should be a non-alcoholic
company until you guys brought alcohol
along yeah me and Timmy has been a lot
more fun drinking that's awesome that's
to fun cuz we're with we're with the
crew right now so it's fun to drink oh
yeah
alone it's those games that's true
drinking along I'm gonna drink alone and
build my tolerance I'm secretary yeah
you never just get when you're like I'm
gonna crack open a beer only what I'm
eating like when I eat I drink more pay
with food yeah like if I'm having a
burger then [ __ ] yes nothing like I'm I
just might treat myself
dude the sound of that beer cracking it
sounds so good though dr. pepper sounds
like that to the core I sound like that
too that's true cause I'm I only drink
soda so when I hear that I want
something sweet and then you taste that
piss-stained yeah I'm not sure that's
true yeah beer does tastes like piss
though not that I know what piss taste
like is just beer does not taste good
you don't have the good beers true it
smells like club soda and in piss oh
there's some good beer bud you're
talking about you're talking about
European Buuren well I'm in the mood for
some light something dark
I like Browns a lot cuz it's kind of
nutty and caramely Hogman the oldest
yeah me a Korean very cranberries I got
you know one of my favorites
ty beard Chang here Chang no I haven't
had that yeah that's really no no I'm at
it at your house yeah it's really good
cheaper than hell - it's so good I've
actually had Bud Light one time and it
didn't [ __ ] me up so maybe I can drink
beer mm-hmm
yeah I like it was it blue is it blue
Bud Light yeah but like you should build
up your tolerance I should if you can't
if you want to because I feel like it's
not really fun to drink with friends and
then to kind of just talk in that
headspace it's a different kind of
conversation I'm annoyed at people that
drink so I want to be I want to be not
sober so I'm not annoyed there you go
yeah true I remember in my twenties I
didn't have a favorite beer because it
didn't genuinely like beer and I was
always disappointed by that like that I
tried it and you have a favorite now but
yeah now I like that mode elbow Videla
negro yeah that's the best wool it's so
good I like a Newcastle that's good -
yeah good trip miss English else I
missed out on a lot of my childhood I
was like four or five yet four or five
it's alright
we haven't at the old office I mean the
new office yeah lot of those I don't
know Ryan bottom yeah I think we were
cleaning the office you know he was like
we got to treat ourselves while we clean
the office it's just a good smooth
non-offensive beer for me that's why I
don't like it you know it's like it's
when I drink it I'm like this is a beer
and that's all I get out of it like it's
just like there's nothing else here like
offensive fierce yeah I do
what's an offensive the vehicles are
they screams out at me as I open up the
can yeah yeah Corona Corona is an
outrage beer yes it's an outrage beer
wait why cuz it's outrageous no no I'm
talking about outrageous flavors right
looks like hoppy beers no I love it
I love it but that's why I'm saying like
it's if it's hoppy it can be a little
offensive do you like the the ones that
like have like fruit essences and stuff
- I don't mind yeah that kind of bomb is
it a mango cart you would like have you
had a mango car you get mango cart you
pour a bunch of Tajin on it
I had a mango lassi you're speaking her
language yeah like it's a from gonna
Road brewery the way you have it is that
you it's you buy any supermarket now you
pour a bunch of Tajin on it so you taste
that Diana you drink it it floats on top
Oh tamarind vodka I've talked about this
before tamarind vodka that's what the
[ __ ] is up Smirnoff does a tamarind
vodka doesn't it good way you just say
oh no no you not got a flavor I usually
mix it yeah it's it's vodka that's me
with Tamra hammer and lick it fruit yeah
yeah yeah and it's like spicy it's a
spicy [ __ ]
whatever the seed yeah I mean doll what
it's like spicy right if you add a
little bit of that Salter into it it's
pretty smooth I think so right comes in
a pod like a pea who comes in two
part-time and Zapata I like me that by
itself it tastes like fruit roll-up yeah
is it dry ders that's actual fruit and
it's like ripeness or is it I can't
drive because like if this kind of got
this like fruit roll-up texture right
like it's like dried out I remember when
I was 20 and buying oh I'll get some
fruit rolls I missed that flavor right
and then I meant to grocery store and
they're like all-natural fruit roll-ups
and I was like oh cool that's probably
better for me I'll try that they're
horrible they're not the same they're
horrible when's the last time you had
sunflower seeds cause I played baseball
I was a kid really I haven't had in a
long time so much work for too little
substance I remember eat him all the
time yeah what happened to me that I
took it out of my life I remember eating
so much that my lips were all like super
salty and like pruney and yeah like your
list yeah I don't even know how to how
to break him up yeah I would just put
him on my mouth and suck on them and
it's been about corn nuts that's like
that's how you play it off
you want someone to do it to like it's
mush and drink it until my friend's dad
taught me how he's like because he was
like boy you're not speeding him out and
I'm like it tastes good and he goes no
not crunchy and he taught me how to like
split it you know you get it on if this
is the scene you get it from this side
and then you smash it on top and it pops
it open and you spit the see I didn't
know that till this day so it never had
instructions in the bag so I always just
I was like the second one
a whole thing I learned how to eat
sunflower seeds from Jim Carrey and Ace
Ventura and night my favorite thing to
do was to eat out of my bellybutton
because that's what he did it he was
like kind of like throw it off to the
side and I'd do exactly that and I'd get
in trouble for throwing off to the side
on the floor and barbecue is the best
flavor though have you had it no okay
they have flavored sunflower seeds it's
like corn nuts yeah the corner you get
the whole thing like oh yeah yeah just
the original one I'm gonna get some
sunflower seeds after this good so I
heard that it's good with beer and huh
the Isaac lady likes to eat them without
the what does it call like the outer
shell yeah the shell shell loose it's
already shelled I've never even tasted
what that is and he likes them unsalted
we're like oh yeah he swallows a whole
yeah pistachios are one of those things
where I feel like it needs to come in
the show because I feel like it feels
wrong to just eat it by itself
the stashes are cheating pistachios are
cool because the amount of work you put
into it you get a lot of reward that's
why I like to go boom open and you eat
it you know it's kind of like if I eat
crab legs I don't want it just already
shelled for me to just eat with a fork
it feels wrong I completely disagree
lounge crab legs I think nuts are fun to
crack I think crab legs is so boring and
frustrating I hate it so you like it
when it's just arty a pile of crabs just
give me the crab yeah
Arnim a sprayer it's a part of the that
the whole experience though cracking the
crab and all that but not the little
crab no yeah it has to be a nice Alaskan
king crab or something you guys to me
you sound like people who miss candle
light no you need to like people miss
candlelight you like like I miss getting
the match and striking it and walking
and going up to the oil lamp and
lighting it up you know I actually have
candles all over my house because I'm
trying to save electricity I'm doing a
challenge of okay so my challenge right
now is how to live on the bare minimums
like lowest utility bills like if I
could really stretch this out never
going to the market I already have my
groceries I'm almost hitting a month now
without going shop
being for groceries that's beautiful
what's the amount you spent so far this
month is that that it's going by a
dollar or not like how I'm well I'm more
I'm not I'm not putting into things like
getting a gym bill or like I'm not
putting into things like you know maybe
workout equipment but I'm just thinking
of things like food and utilities yeah
so what does it look like when I'm home
all the time and like let's say you
might be going out to eat right but then
your gas bill might be low because
you're not using the fryer or whatever
but then that might go up yeah it's
never been a problem because it's pretty
cheap yeah but electricity pretty sick
yeah it's like can i how long can I go
without turning on the AC or whatever in
water so that's kind of like how
showering
I have to shower but you're not using AC
right now huh are you not using AC right
now I'm trying my best not to it's hot
as [ __ ]
it got hot like overnight with in one
day it's like ah cloudy and gloomy and
rainy for so long I love that weather I
loved it and now it's [ __ ] hot yeah
so seven AC is broken right now - no my
girlfriend's working from home and I'm
like sucks for you I'm gonna be here
we're so lucky if you don't live in like
Thailand now oh yeah [ __ ] hot it's
crazy
you have to have AC in every dwelling I
had a half broken a/c when me and Nikki
were in Bali for our honeymoon and it
was nuts it was it was not oh my god for
your honeymoon
there was only one AC I mean not anyone
your wedding for there was a little one
AC on the whole property yeah and
everyone was like [ __ ] is so hot no
super hot I always felt so bad for
medieval nights during the summertime me
too because there in like that metal
armor just sway their ass off wonder if
the armor burns them or not oh yeah like
at some point because they meet they're
like it's alright son and it's just
metal on metal on metal so I get rusty
it reflects it like a mirror but if you
want a little bit um foil don't you get
cooked inside after true I'm never tried
we should ask a Ren Faire guy never know
are you like a big ham I feel like the
Ren Faire guys are really into it
because it would like they would start
sweating and start smelling really bad
and you're like yeah we snuff and - [ __ ]
yeah we smell like [ __ ] but the funny
thing is those guys don't look like the
guys in medieval times I don't know
sometimes I wonder like what would it be
like to visit that era horrible you guys
should come to me to medieval times with
me when it is reopened yeah let's do it
because it's like it's like being in
that era oh yeah they had chicken
nuggets and everything yeah I've been to
medieval times where they do the
jousting show and all that and then they
bring out food and then they lower the
gates because people [ __ ] chuck
things at the jousters oh dude I was
really they do that I was screaming my
head up at the red Knight I was [ __ ]
like you suck we [ __ ] hate the red
knight what color are you right so I
guess later on in the tournament they
all go to different teams and then he
was eventually T partnered with the
Green Knight or whatever or whatever my
team was and then I was booing him still
cuz I was riding his ass the whole show
and then and then he turns to me and
he's like I'm on your team he breaks
character in his [ __ ] piss well I was
lighting him up tears drooling down the
side of his cheek and he's like hey buck
man every time he rode close to my group
I would [ __ ] lie lay into that guy
man I'm like [ __ ] we hate the red
neither a night sucks only cuz he took
my night out he was a he was [ __ ]
with my night what the urine wasn't even
your night cuz I have the same color I
know I hope they don't go out of
business off after this so on on that
same street in Buena Park right they
have medieval times and right next to
them they have the pirate oh I've been
to that one the pirate shows hilarious
now my guys are like teams on that one
yeah okay that when we went with NAT
what time the whole night at was going
this is pretty baby and right Praveena
dude this was like 10 years ago or
something yeah don't worry babe yet no
this was like yeah way more because
exercising is right to use the f-word to
it oh my god
right wait he said he said the g-word no
he's using that family uh when the
f-word was okay I guess you've never
used that word before
Hey it was never okay to use on a gay
person I feel but on everybody else
especially guys wearing capes yeah
absolutely appropriate and one of the
the seamen were fans to the seamen yeah
it was pretty funny I hope that she
can't in that kind of should we open man
before all this happen and then he was
working about yeah could you get us a
discount probably does he know the red
night can he tell can you give him a
message for me say sorry it's foggy he
actually is the red night now too
your job is to joust all [ __ ] night
those guys they get hit with the shields
and stuff to write em up back in the
days or import apart at Bonaparte in
medieval times you know scary you could
just lose a limb or die in a second yeah
and you got no health insurers running
at each other full-speed and I mean they
they use them I think they use wood
[ __ ] sticks but it's still like oh it
isn't a break right well we see a break
though I have two shows real impact
I was drinking so much I have no idea
one of the most impressive things
there's as part of this show um there's
a guy with like uh was it mace right
it's like a chain being with like a
spiky ball yeah he swings it around cuz
I've been to medieval time like many
times and he smashes into this guy with
the metal helmet and it actually makes
impact really loud obviously it's still
like like prop weapons and stuff yeah I
think whiter material but you can hear
it sounds loudest [ __ ] it sounds like if
I took a baseball bat and hit someone's
good with it I'm like man like the way
they act because it's pretty much 360
audience so unlike movies where you can
cheat shots they really still have to
make impacts
that's true that's how I could know that
I was getting to the red Knight because
he could never quite escape
yeah he couldn't leave to like actually
[ __ ] there and shrug it's like
[Laughter]
if you guys could travel back into those
days like what would be the first thing
you want to do I'll bring a machine gun
that's not bringing oh you know but like
yeah okay fine if you're gonna find
loopholes you get no loophole travel
there exactly as you are without seeking
anything in fact you're gonna show up
naked no clothes on nothing
you show up this bar I'm showing up
modest you probably be one of the
biggest guys there oh yeah probably give
it for how long I wouldn't have all your
cool jams and stuff and then sure enough
protein shine up he's gonna shake I'll
be eating [ __ ] like a squirrel
protein bars that's fine
I don't know room-temperature beer or
like warm beer I mean it's a mead mead
warm mead yeah give me the mead and I
find the alcohol was really chill back
then like the the content like it was it
was like really low percentage yeah I
heard alcohol was real I mean that's why
everyone drank too cuz it was you know
is that a cleaner than what drinking
water heroin just rang out whoa like the
percentage was super low which I could
probably drink I don't want to wear one
of those gowns like the like a wench
gown Oh went great no wenches are just
rags and I know what you're talking
about because they like get like four
sets and stuff and handling all their
titties always popping out of those
movies always yeah that's like
Oktoberfest titties yeah that's what I
want to wear medieval although you
should wear that there you go they sold
those outfits in like Austria and
Germany
yeah that's to wear casually I don't
know if it's casual but it's like they
had them on this at the tourist places
you guys should dress up like that while
you're a medieval Austrian wench and
then you're in like the Chinese picked I
love it
so medieval racial [ __ ] this bean
version of that oh yeah what if we still
dress the way that like like we like our
ancestors did all of us and we kept that
style
oh yeah but we're all living together
like no blue - yeah that would be so
[ __ ] crazy do you think that because
we have knowledge of like the clitoris
and and stuff now knowledge of the
clitoris it's like if we were to take
that instead of them I know you wanna
take machine gun back and win wars I
would take just my general sex knowledge
back and be king of sex for that time
yeah but you wouldn't want to [ __ ] any
of the girls back then be hairy as [ __ ]
the dirtiest [ __ ] freakiest muck dan you
look disgusting but what effect in what
if back then that smell is what turn
people on oh I think they just had a
deal yeah I think they get D sensible
things and everyone smells like that
that's true maybe we look and smell
horrendous to future people no you just
got to go to a Muslim country or Korea
or Japan or something like that for what
because they always babe or the or
ancient Greece or ancient Rome ancient
Rome they always might feel like oh like
the guy who's like not even that good at
sex going back in time could just rock
it you think there's still some that
rumors yeah but then you're gonna have
to every single girl that you have you
have you have to keep unless you are a
Mongolian Raider
that was different okay I'll be among
them if you're a Mongolia radio trader
you just go into the village and you put
them on your horse and then you just
leave how do I say I'm a Mongolian mater
just keep repeating it over and over
again like in the movies yeah in Raider
I feel like the theme Solt although if
you wrote a horse's feet still drive
over floor although Chinese when
outdoors tours
I would hate to be a peasant back then I
know you just constantly [ __ ] you know
wooden hate to be a peasant now well we
are peasants now but now we're better
peasant applause we can't like back then
some look just bully the [ __ ] out of you
yeah because the the King literally owns
all human beings in their realm so it's
like all the peasants are [ __ ] my
property and all the muddy carriages are
always going by and splashing you yeah a
nice carriage is coming out coming
through a town didn't know the poor
people oh and they're looking up at the
horse I who's inside and they just stay
there - for more you're used to it
alright and then they just keep getting
splashing splashing splash that's our
whole daily lives
[Music]
[Music]